actually just on a small tangent since
you are also a car guy uh what's the
greatest uh combustion engine car ever
made to you if you had to pick something
what's the like the coolest the sexiest
the most powerful the classiest the most
elegant well-designed I don't know what
a lot of those things are different for
me but they are I still it's funny
because now maybe it's just because it's
fresh on mine but I love
that mid 90s RX7 which you know
especially in Japan they had the the 20b
a tri-rotor
that is like the coolest engine ever to
me
the fdrx7
it's just too darn cool honestly
maybe uh uh there you go well what about
the mid 90s that makes it special just
that's the only time it's more that I
love the engine and I and I like the car
it's attached to him and I'm not
actually a big fan of like 90s styling
you know personally but just that the
20b is just such a cool cool engine and
it's twin turbo sequential turbos so
they used um they a bigger turbo takes
longer to spool up you know it takes
more it's using that same like a turbine
and a compressor and it just if it's a
large turbine it takes more exhaust gas
to get it spooled up so if you have an
engine that revs to 9000 RPM and you
want to get a lot of pressure out of
that turbo you have a big turbo it's
going to take forever like you're gonna
have you know your floor and then like
right it's gonna take a long time for
that turbo to get spooled up so they
actually did a small turbo on it and a
big turbo so the small turbo would spool
up first get some boost going through
the engine get that engine operating get
it up to speed get it you know get some
power to the wheels and then once that
kind of reaches its limit you'd flow it
into the divert the exhaust gas into the
bigger turbo it's this sequential turbo
and then that now can supplement and
actually increase the you know overall
performance of the of the vehicle by a
lot and I just I think that's just so
cool it's it's just like the ultimate
like Brute Force out of the box thinking
and it actually made it into production
you know what I mean can you uh what's
the sound like can you tell an engine by
its sound it sounds like a really really
really angry lawnmower
it sounds horrible it's actually a
terrible sounding car in my opinion like
it sounds just raspy and like the
opposite of like a big muscle car yeah
like a big muscle car is deep gotta roll
like deep oh it just it hits you this is
like it's just gonna annoy the hell out
of you and all your neighbors like it's
but you love the engineering I love the
engineering of it so to you the car is
the engine it's not all the surface
stuff all the design stuff uh all the
you know yeah the the Elegance the
curves Whatever It Is Well those come
and go you know to me Styles change just
forever yeah I'm gonna apply that to my
uh dating life once again the metaphors
just keep on coming well if you think
about it like my taste has changed
throughout the years when I first saw uh
a model 3 Tesla I thought it was the
most hideous Carver without the gorilla
I was like this is so stupid it took me
all but two months to think that it was
one of the coolest looking cars same
with cyber truck I'm mourned cyber truck
when I first saw that thing I was at
that that thing with and I went with uh
we used to do a podcast called our
ludicrous future so we talked a lot
about like you know cars and EVs and
stuff we went to that unveiling and
literally like we had like almost a
non-alcohol-induced hangover the next
morning of like morning the hideousness
of cyber truck
come six months later a year later and
I'm like damn it that thing's actually
kind of cool yeah that also teaches you
just something about again it's the
thing you said uh earlier sort of uh
going against
the the current of the experts of the
beliefs or whatever is and and making
the decision from first principles some
of that also applies to design and
styling and fashion and culture and all
big time uh some of that you know so
fashion especially is so interesting so
being rebellious
against the current the the current fads
actually is the way to pave
the new fads when it didn't take long
for others to follow you look at like
currently like what Hyundai is doing
with their I forget which one like the
ionic or something like that it's it's
Square it's like it's boxy you know it's
it's a throwback it's 80s it's got these
beautiful retro tail lights it's got
these Square headlights it's it's it's
very inspired by cyber truck in my
opinion I mean it might not be it might
be coincidental that we're all kind of
getting this feature Vibe but uh I
personally like the boxy so I never I
just still haven't understood uh
Porsches Porsches I still can't quite
understand the small size the elegant
the curves I don't I don't quite get it
like I said I don't love the look of the
RX7 I don't love it but I love it
because of the engineering I guess that
it represents you know what I mean yeah
it's it's uh it's not the surface stuff
it's the deep down stuff it's that 50 50
weight distribution that matters